-Our next guest
is a talented actor
you know from movies
such as "Booksmart."
He stars in the film "Moxie"
which is streaming now
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-Wait. So how many sisters
do you have?
-Three. All older.
-I'll bet you were
a pretty cute kid.
[ Both chuckle ]
-Yeah, it was --
it was all right.
I-I got my hair braided a lot.
I also know all the names
to the American Girl dolls
-Do you really?
-Yeah.
-No, you don't.
-Josefina, Molly, Addy....
-Oh, my God.
-Please welcome to the sho
Nico Hiraga.
How are you, Nico?
-What's up, man?
How we doing?
-We're doing really well.
So, obviously,
the director of this film,
Amy Poehler,
I've known her for years.
I'm curious what your experience
with her was.
How was she as a director?
-It was surreal. She's great
She's a force of nature.
I tell everyone the same thing
I'll try and switch it up
a little bit.
Like, you can't really
put it into words, but she -
-I will say I've also used
"force of nature"
to describe her,
so sometimes it's just
the right set of words.
-I've used "force of nature.
I've used "she's a beast."
I've used "she's a tank."
I've used "she's serious but
also witty and funny at times.
She's, like,
everything and above
you could ever ask for, man,
really.
-I'm wondering -- 'Cause you
and I are about the same age
-Yeah, yeah, right, right.
-[ Laughter ]
-What of her work
were you most familiar wit
before you did this?
-Um...
[ Laughs ]
"Sisters." It was "Sisters."
-"Sisters" with Tina Fey.
-Yeah.
It was "Sisters"
and "Baby Mama."
"Baby Mom"?
-Yeah, yeah. That's right.
-"Baby Mama."
It was "Sisters"
and "Baby Mama."
I didn't know much about
"Parks and Rec."
I didn't know much about "SNL.
But I definitely knew
about "Sisters,"
and that movie hit it
over the head, man.
That was a good one.
-You should go back
to those "SNLs."
She does this fake-news thing.
Very good.
-Yeah?
-Guy she does it with
is fantastic.
-Oh, really?
I'm guessing that's you.
-[ Laughter ]
-Hey, so, in this film,
you skateboard a little bit,
and part of me thinks,
"Wow, that's really cool
that an actor would learn
how to skateboard."
But this actually --
Amy had to tell you
to skateboard worse
than do you in real life.
You are very good at this.
-Yeah, so, I don't know --
Sorry. My legs are --
I don't know why my legs
are sitting up on the desk
like that.
But -- Sorry. Yeah.
No, yeah, I am a skateboarde
before I started acting.
And Amy did kind of want m
to tone it down a little bit
I think she got
a little bit nervous there
because, you know,
we're filming at a school
and usually most, like,
really good skate spots
are at schools,
and there was, like, this --
this stair set that
I wanted to go down and be like,
"Yo, how about I come
into the shot,
like, come down the stair set,
you know, like, do a trick
down the five stair,
come around,
carve around this extra,
and then stop right here?"
And she's like,
"Let's just have you do,
like, skate on flat ground."
I was like, "All right.
Yeah, yeah, that works, too.
No worries, no worries."
But, yeah, I definitely --
I started off skating
before acting.
-Just for those who think
you're making it up,
we're gonna roll some vide
that you posted on Instagram
So this is --
this is you in real life.
And this is far more --
Oh, well, now, Nico,
that's why
she wouldn't let you do it
She can't have an actor
break bones during filming
Have you hurt yourself
a good amount over the years
-Absolutely.
[ Laughter ]
-It does not seem
to have put you off it.
-Yeah, no. Absolutely.
I've taken out I think 12 --
Broken 12 bones?
I've broken a handful, yeah.
Some of the worst ones --
Like, I split my head open
right here.
Tore a ligament in my ankle.
Oh, the coccyx, your tailbone,
your butt bone.
-Yeah.
-Broke that three times.
Dude, that thing's the worst
Then you got to bring
a donut to school.
-Uh-huh.
-Yeah, that -- that one's --
Those are --
Your tailbone's hectic.
-Yeah. I mean, I'm not
going to lie to you.
I think if I broke it once
I'd be out of the game.
-Hey, there's only one way
to find out.
Let's get you skating, Seth.
-If I can borrow your donut.
-I got you.
Dude, I got like three.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, you're obviously
a man of taste.
But I was very psyched to hear
that your celebrity crush
is not who I think --
I think anybody
watching right now
might try to guess
your celebrity crush,
and they would not guess
who I'm about to say it is
Would you verify
that it is Maggie Smith
in "Harry Potter"?
[ Laughter ]
-For days!
For days. Yo.
Like, I didn't even know
her name was Maggie Smith
for a while.
I just knew
Professor McGonagall.
And I was like --
I was like, "Oh, my God."
Like, when she was doing
the duel battle with Snape
I don't want to give anythin
away about "Harry Potter."
But I was like, "Yo...
Professor McGonagall, dude
like..."
The Wicked Witch, man.
She is great.
-Well, look, I just want to sa
it has been a delight
talking to you.
I want to thank you
for being here.
I really want to thank you
for not spoiling
"Harry Potter" for people.
I think...
-I got you, Seth.
No worries, man.
Lips are sealed.
-Hey, keep up
the great work, man.
Come back soon.
It was a delight meeting you
-Hey, it was nice meeting you,
Seth. Appreciate it.